Hulk has clashed with the Avengers countless
times, but usually, it's out of love.
Earth's Mightiest Heroes are often just trying
to protect innocent people from Hulk's rampages.
Fair enough, but sometimes, the Avengers could
just be super-jerks to the Green Goliath.
While Hulk was technically one of the original
Avengers in 1963's Avengers #1, the group's
founding was largely a hunt for the man-monster.
Much like the movie adaptation, Avengers #1
saw Loki accidentally forming the Avengers
while trying to use Hulk to defeat his half-brother
Thor.
When Loki shows up, the Hulk is in hiding,
acting as a performer in a circus.
Later, when the Hulk uses his colossal strength
to save a train on a broken track, Loki uses
his illusions to make it appear the Hulk was
the culprit who wrecked the tracks in the
first place.
Rick Jones and his Teen Brigade call out with
ham radios to any heroes who could help stem
the Hulk's threat and Iron Man, Ant-Man, and
the Wasp answer.
The three soon-to-be-teammates spend most
of Avengers #1 chasing the Hulk and battling
him in a factory.
Before anyone gets seriously hurt, Thor arrives
with Loki as his prisoner, having figured
out Loki's scheme.
While the now-iconic cover of Avengers #1
depicts the five original Avengers battling
Loki, the only one who truly threw down with
him was Thor.
The Hulk did nothing but fight off his attackers,
who believed the lie that the Hulk was nothing
more than a rampaging beast.
The Hulk's time in the Avengers was short-lived.
He quit at the end of Avengers #2, and considering
everything, it's tough to blame him.
In Avengers #2, the team was infiltrated by
an alien villain named the Space Phantom who
could mimic the appearance of different heroes.
Unsurprisingly, he chose the Hulk as his victim,
and used the giant green monster to beat up
the Avengers a bit before switching into a
different body.
When the smoke cleared and everyone realized
what had happened, the Hulk was angry at what
the Avengers said about him when they believed
they were fighting him.
"Earth hate Hulk."
"Earth love Hulk!
They love you, you're one of the Avengers,
one of the team!
Our friend!
This is what friends do, they support each
other."
That could have been the end of it, but in
Avengers #3, the Avengers actively hunted
the Hulk and battled him once more.
The Hulk fought them off and eventually allied
himself with the aquatic outcast Namor the
Sub-Mariner in an attempt to destroy the team
and get them off his back.
In 1988, the High Evolutionary was ticking
off the whole Marvel Universe in an event
called Evolutionary War, which ran through
Marvel's annuals.
The finale was in Avengers Annual #17, but
there was a problem: the Avengers had disbanded.
An alarm summoned a band of reserve Avengers
anyway.
At the end of Incredible Hulk #350, Hulk is
finishing an epic battle with The Thing of
the Fantastic Four, when X-Men's Beast happens
upon the Hulk and strong-arms him into helping
the Avengers.
At the time, most of the world believed the
Hulk had died in a gamma bomb explosion a
few issues earlier… except he didn't.
Instead, a gray, more intelligent version
of the Hulk had survived and relocated to
Las Vegas, and he liked the world thinking
he was dead.
So, the Beast did exactly what any honorable,
heroic member of the Avengers and the X-Men
would do: He told the Hulk if he didn't help
the Avengers, he'd reveal to the entire world
that he was still alive, making him a wanted
man-monster once more.
How heroic.
It's no secret the Hulk tends to hold a grudge.
But in Marvel Comics, the Hulk isn't the only
one who knows how to hold onto a beef.
In 1995's Incredible Hulk #434, the Avengers
threw the first punch.
The issue immediately followed the Over the
Edge event, in which Nick Fury has been killed,
and the Avengers blame the Hulk for Fury's
death.
As soon as the Hulk shows up to the funeral,
the Avengers attack him.
It was even the usually rational android Vision
who starts everything by using his phasing
powers to shove his finger into the Hulk's
brain.
Somewhat surprisingly, the Hulk hardly fights
back, uncharacteristically trying to talk
his way out of a fight.
When the Avengers lock horns with the Hulk
in 1986's Incredible Hulk #316, they battle
a different kind of Hulk.
The gamma-powered hero Doc Samson had developed
a method to physically separate Bruce Banner
from his greener half.
As a result, an utterly mindless Hulk was
raging through the New Mexico desert destroying
everything he saw.
That leads the Avengers send their four physically
strongest members - Hercules, Namor, Wonder
Man, and Iron Man - to stop him.
It makes sense the Avengers would want to
take out such a destructive version of the
green goliath, but half of the quartet formed
in the desert to tussle with the Hulk don't
even bother to take it seriously.
Wonder Man acts like the pampered Hollywood
socialite that he was at the time, and Hercules
in particular treats the whole thing like
a game.
That wouldn't be the last time that the Avengers
attacked the Hulk to prevent untold destruction.
During Civil War II, the Inhuman Ulysses'
psychic vision shows the original Hulk on
a rampage, apparently murdering most of Marvel's
heroes.
When those heroes confront Banner, they discover
he's researching gamma radiation, and are
less than happy with the implications.
A huge group of heroes confront Banner.
Because the best thing you can do to someone
with anger issues is surround him with as
many people as possible while yelling at him.
"Clearly your friend is in desperate need
of help."
"Yeah, yeah, yeah."
"We realized we also need as many people attacking
this guy as we can possibly get."
Before anything can be resolved, Hawkeye murders
Bruce Banner.
Sort of.
A flashback reveals that Banner had actually
created the arrows that Clint Barton used
to kill him, and that he had given them to
the archer in case he should ever need to
be put down.
Hawkeye claims he saw Banner's eyes flash
green before he fired off the fatal shot,
but whether or not that was true is left purposefully
ambiguous.
While the Avengers and Hulk were both still
stinging from a couple of recent clashes,
Earth's Mightiest and the Hulk were forced
to work together for the Marvel-wide comics
event Onslaught.
While things never got violent between Hulk
and his former teammates, it wasn't for lack
of the Avengers trying.
In Incredible Hulk #445, the Hulk gets so
tired of the Avengers giving him dirty looks
everywhere he went that he tells them so.
In spite of Hulk telling them to stop unless
they wanted him to join "the other side,"
the heroes continue to look at him like they
would love nothing more than for the green
goliath to try something.
By the way, treating the Hulk like garbage
during Onslaught wasn't just an Avengers game.
After the event finale in Onslaught: Marvel
Universe #1 - when the Hulk provided the decisive
blow against Onslaught by cracking the villain's
supposedly impenetrable armor - the Avengers
and the Fantastic Four disappear and are presumed
dead.
The Hulk is left lying on the ground and the
X-Men just… leave him there.
They don't even mention him.
Without him, Onslaught would have won, but
the heroes didn't seem to care.
Not all of the Avengers' unwarranted assaults
on the Hulk occurred in Marvel's heyday.
As recently as 2018, Immortal Hulk #6 ends
with the Avengers tracking down the newly-resurrected
Bruce Banner to capture him.
One of the biggest reasons for their attack
was a battle between the Hulk and the Canadian
hero Sasquatch in a hospital.
Immortal Hulk #7 opens with every indication
that the Avengers are not going to get their
way.
The Hulk proves more powerful than ever, hitting
Thor so hard that Captain America has to carry
him from the battlefield.
The Hulk rips up yet another Hulkbuster armor
to pieces, and takes out his cousin She-Hulk
with a single punch.
Unfortunately for Hulk, Black Panther and
Tony Stark have a powerful energy cannon orbiting
the Earth, ready to take him out if the Avengers
can't do it themselves.
Unable to stop him any other way, the Avengers
kill the Hulk with the cannon, knowing that
he'll come back, since he always does.
"Go to sleep go to sleep go to sleep."
Comics aren't the only medium in which the
Avengers treat the Hulk like trash.
Sure, usually in the movies when the Hulk
clashes with his teammates, he's the one to
initiate the throwdown, so it's hard to blame
them.
But what about a scene that isn't a fight?
What about a scene that was an audience pleaser
in the theaters?
Toward the end of Avengers: Age of Ultron,
after Bruce Banner frees Black Widow from
Ultron's prison, he's ready to go with Widow's
idea to skedaddle and live on the run with
her.
He doesn't seem at all scared of helping the
Avengers fight Ultron, at least not for himself…
but the last time he transformed it was under
the Scarlet Witch's influence, and he ended
up going on a deadly rampage.
It's something he doesn't want to repeat.
Black Widow takes the choice out of Banner's
hands; she pushes him off a ledge, forcing
him to transform into the Hulk to save himself.
Why?
"I need the other guy.
Let's finish the job."
It may have gotten applause in the theater,
but considering how close Bruce and Natasha
had grown, and how harrowing an experience
it is for Banner to transform into the Hulk
and back, Widow's push is a chilling betrayal.
No Asgardian hammer or titanium fist could
wound him more.
And of course who could forget Planet Hulk?
In 2005, Bruce Banner agrees to help S.H.I.E.L.D.
take out a dangerous space-based Hydra weapon.
Unfortunately, it's a trap.While the Hydra
threat was presumably real, the primary purpose
of Hulk's recruitment was to get him into
space.
Once he completes his mission and boards the
shuttle that he thought would take him home,
the ship heads off in a different direction
and a recorded message plays.
Four members of Marvel's Illuminati - Mister
Fantastic, Iron Man, Doctor Strange, and Black
Bolt - appear before the Hulk, explaining
to him that they are sending him away, both
for his own good and that of the Earth.
The betrayal leads to one of the most memorable
and well-loved Hulk stories of recent memory,
Planet Hulk.
That storyline also leads to the follow-up
revenge story, 2007's World War Hulk, which
sees the Hulk smash all four of his betrayers
as well as a healthy chunk of the rest of
Marvel's heroes.
At the end of the day, there's one thing you
can always count on Hulk to do:
"Hulk Smash!"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.